[Musique]
je peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui 100% de
nos agences sont ouvertes dans les
yvelines
alors on est ouverts certes mon travail
différemment avec des agences qui sont
ouvertes au niveau du libre service
bancaire c'est l'endroit où vous pouvez
faire vos opérations sur les automates
les libre service bancaire ouvert le
matin aux horaires habituels de lagence
et toute la journée
les conseillers sont joignables à
distance par leurs clients donc on
continue à travailler et être à l'écouté
de nos clients mais différemment
[Musique]
deux choses déjà les pose sur les
crédits ça dès qu'on organise des pauses
sur sur les crédits là on en a fait je
regardais sur notre direction régionale
depuis le début de la crise 1371 pause
et puis maintenant la grande actualité
c'est le prêt garanti par l'état le prêt
auquel ont droit des entreprises jusqu'à
25 % de leur chiffre d'affaires 2010 9
c'est la grosse activité du moment tous
nos conseillers sont sur le pool des
clients examine leurs besoins et on est
en cours d'instruction et déjà les
premiers dossiers ont été réalisés
[Musique]
et crédits à l'habitat sont un peu à
l'arrêt en ce moment les nos beaux
projets sont plutôt à l'arrêt mais il
nous reste tous les anciens projets qui
étaient avait commencé à instruire avant
crise et qu'on finalise avec les clients
naturellement parce que on a la chance
d'avoir encore nos services de back
office qui sont complètement
opérationnels et qui peuvent assurer la
réalisation des opérations jusqu'au bout
on a aussi pas mal de préoccupation de
particulier sur les marchés financiers
qui sont particulièrement agitée en ce
moment la bourse alors beaucoup de
questions est ce que ces deux mamans
dachier est-ce que c'est trop tôt est ce
que c'est trop tard comment y aller et
donc là on est très très sollicité un
conseil sur sur ces sujets là il faut
reconnaître que les pouvoirs publics
avaient agisse avec détermination pour
maintenir la confiance à on a vu il ya
beaucoup de mesures pour les petites en
place
le chômage partiel l'aller mais report
d'impôt de charges sociales les différer
de crédit des banques des prêts donc
tout ça devrait être de nature à limiter
l'impact financier même si on aura de
toute façon la question qui pourrait se
poser c'est est ce que les banques sont
solides pour assurer aussi cette période
par rapport à 2008 inquiéter la dernière
crise très très forte inconnu des
banques
la situation est plus du tout la même
dans la mesure où les mesures de
renforcement des fonds propres ont été
très très forte
ça lui consomme au dos les banques à
doubler leur niveau de fonds propres par
rapport à cette période là donc elles
sont beaucoup plus solides
actuellement pour accompagner les ce
crise économique et se met au service de
l'économie réelle justement